financial markets have been on an
absolute tear over the last 12 months
everything seems to be going up over and
over and over again over the weekend i
was speaking at a conference and one of
the things that came up was everyone was
saying why should i go ahead and look at
other assets if my portfolio was going
up well when you start to think about a
portfolio and i asked you how did your
portfolio do over the last 12 months
what you would quote me is the nominal
rate of return you would say well the s
p 500 is up 29 over the last 12 months
so my portfolio was up 29 but if i asked
you what the real rate of return is you
would take that nominal number 29 and
you would subtract the six plus percent
inflation so actually you were doing
somewhere around
22.5
on a real return basis sounds pretty
good right no here is one of the big
things that i think most people are
going to start to wrap their heads
around is that when you are quoting the
financial return of your portfolio
you're comparing it to dollars it's a
medium of exchange it's a currency that
dollar is not a fixed amount of value
instead that dollar is actually being
devalued at a historic rate right now
that's where you get the 6
plus inflation and so what you're doing
is you're taking the asset itself the
one share the one piece of property the
one commodity and you are denominating
it in a depreciating value if the stock
market went up 29
how much of the 29 gain in the stock
market is because the dollar has been
devaluing or the stock market is
actually creating and capturing upside
value you can't really measure it and so
ultimately what i think more and more
people are going to do and what i
personally have started to do is i
denominate my entire portfolio in
bitcoin why well bitcoin is a finite
supply asset its inflation rate right
now is 1.78 that is lower than anything
else from a currency perspective that is
considered a major currency that people
would denominate their portfolios and so
if you go ahead and you compare bitcoin
and let's say the s p 500 if we
denominated over the entire lifetime
bitcoin
denominated in the s p here we go it has
fallen off a cliff the s p 500 has been
crashing the s p 500 is negative when
denominated in bitcoin remember this is
a fix supply asset that is a
programmatic monetary policy that no one
can manipulate what you are looking at
right here is an absolute destruction of
the s p 500 value in a portfolio when
compared with a digital store of value
we then go ahead and we look over the
last year you can see that they're also
same exact story it has been falling
very very rapidly now many people will
say why should i think about this in
terms of bitcoin being the denomination
of my portfolio it's not an argument for
you to go and take majority of your
portfolio and put it into bitcoin rather
it's the exact opposite it is the
perspective that says if i want to
maintain the purchasing power of the
digital store of value then i need to
outperform bitcoin so some people go and
they will just buy the store value other
people will actually attempt to
outperform it and so when you go ahead
and you look at that you can compare it
to the historical example of people will
look at the dollar they'll say they're
six percent inflation i have to beat six
percent to actually be able to gain more
dollars well when it comes to bitcoin
bitcoin has been going up a lot for a
long time it's up over 300 over the last
12 months and it has compounded annually
for a decade at 180 percent 180
compound annual growth rate for a decade
which means that if your portfolio has
not been able to achieve 180 compound
annual growth rate then you quite
literally have been losing purchasing
power when measured by the digital store
value of bitcoin and so whether you look
at stocks whether you look at
commodities whether you look at bonds or
any other asset what you find is that
denominating your portfolio in dollars
continues to go up and up and up why
well this is true of every single
country that has high levels of
inflation many years there are the best
performing stock markets located in
venezuela zimbabwe argentina or other
places with high levels of inflation
because quite literally the currency in
which the stocks are denominated is
rapidly losing value it looks like the
stock prices are exploding but it's not
because necessarily the companies are
becoming more valuable it's because the
currencies are being devalued if you
were to take the stock market and
denominate it in gold as well the stock
market does not look nearly as
attractive when it starts to be
denominated in terms of an asset that is
not manipulated from a supply
perspective and so ultimately i think
that people are gonna have to wake up to
the fact that denominating your wealth
denominating your portfolio in some sort
of sound money principle looking at it
and saying what is the thing that no one
can change no one can debase no one can
take away that supply that programmatic
transparent monetary policy and that my
friends is why so many people feel like
i'm getting rich on paper but i can't
get ahead well it's because actually if
you were to look at the unofficial uh
inflation numbers it's not six percent
it's closer to 15 and so if you're not
delivering a 15 plus return on your
portfolio then you literally are falling
behind the unofficial inflation number
and if you were to look at bitcoin you'd
have to be delivering over 300
over the last 12 months